that looks so good I can't wait I know
I've gotta catch another room screening
before comes out this would kind of be a
good time to watch the movie you know
I've never actually seen it what yeah I
just never sat down to watch it I mean
it's my favorite nostalgic critic review
but I never did actually bother watching
the full movie you've never seen the
room let's watch it
that was the most unbelievable thing
I've ever seen I I think I love it I
shouldn't but I do
why well you know what they say love is
blind I've got to do a top five on this
teacher will you join me go on will you
do it top five with me
go on if a lot of people love each other
the world would be a better place to
live with the disaster artist hitting
theaters very soon it's time to shine a
spotlight on what started it all get
your phone's ready the room is an
unexplainable anomaly the movie is
filled with ambition that is so
impossibly determined it's amazing in
spite of itself and its eccentric
director slash star / writer / pretty
much everything Tommy was so originally
released in 2003 the room has amassed a
legion of dedicated fans worldwide its
popularity as a cult classic has only
grown over the years with interactive
screenings being shown all over to the
followers of this truly one-of-a-kind
film its enigmatic creator has become a
point of obsession for this fan base
where is he from
how did you fund the room which stupid
comments are we supposed to leave in our
pocket Tommy Wiseau has embraced his
fame and the man behind this project
continues to revel in the success of his
disasterpiece
Greg Sestero mark in the room wrote a
book about his experiences with Tommy
which is what the new movie is based on
and the disaster artist covers a lot of
the rooms most ridiculous moments but
which are the best or worst they're
pretty much indistinguishable but that
doesn't matter these are the top 5 best
/ worst moments from the room
number five you're not my fucking mother
you listen oh boy somebody had better do
something around here this whole scene
is amazing it might be the most
ridiculously chaotic part of the movie
following Chris ARS violent attempt to
get his drug money from Deni Lisa and
Claudette scold the young man for
associating with such a dangerous person
confusion and pendemonium ensue and it's
hilarious somehow this has the timing of
a wild improv sketch through the
repeated yelling and hysteria this
sequence has several classic lines it's
nothing like that I just needed some
money to pay off some stuff how much do
you have to give him this is not the way
you make money how much stop ganging up
on me and is maybe Denny's shining
moment
it's the unintentionally perfect mix of
whining screaming escalation incoherence
and pure insanity that leaves you
stunned and somehow wanting more and
Tommy doesn't even show up till the very
end
denne Lisa and Claudette basically pull
off a flawless three stooges bit yeah
that makes no sense but neither does
this I love it as nuts as this was we're
only scratching the surface
number four nobody wants to help me and
I'm dying you're not dying mom I got the
results of the tests back I definitely
have breast cancer you ever have someone
spring a life-changing revelation on you
in such a mundane way hate when that
happens
Claudia is blabbing on about how her
brother wants to buy her house or
something and out of nowhere she brings
up that she has life-threatening cancer
the best part about this completely
random information it's never brought up
again not once not even in passing it's
just I have cancer okay
it's definitely Claudette's most famous
line in the movie and one that is as
nonchalant as offering someone a mint
it's absolutely a signature moment in
the film where else would you see
something like that only on Tommy's
planet that's where we're going to move
on to number three now and I definitely
have polio
number three you are lying I never hit
you
you got a me apart Lisa why are you so
hysterical do you understand life do you
iconic never have six words come
together so well to perfectly express
one's emotions johnny is finally
confronting Lisa about her spring the
rumor that he hit her she's being very
distant and johnny has just had enough
he's very sensitive you know
the poor guy can only take so much
before he snaps and lets out his
frustration we do know that tommy was
trying to emulate a james dean life
let's take a look and compare Tammy
partly job
yep exactly the same a lot of people
would argue that this is the best /
worst line and moment from the movie
they wouldn't be wrong it's taken out a
life of its own and when people quote
the room this is often the first thing
they say and talk about with all due
respect to James Dean I think we all
know who nailed this line more I want to
see Tommy and Inside the Actors Studio
so he can discuss his delivery here can
we make that happen Internet number two
hi can I help you yeah can I have a
dozen red roses please oh hi Johnny I
didn't know was you here you go that's
me how much is it it'll be $18 go keep
the change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye this scene speaks for
itself it's so simple there isn't much
to explain Johnny goes into a flower
shop buy some flowers pets a dog and
leaves somehow Tommy Wiseau made that
simple act one of the most memorable
parts of the movie it's flawless in its
fuel you're rushed pace when this scene
starts its greetings of the room people
immediately start cheering let's watch
it one more time how much is it it'll be
$18 go keep the change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye there are so many
things wrong with those few seconds that
it's instantly genius I want to go to
that flower shop I want to order a dozen
red roses
I want the clerk to keep the change I
want to pet that dog you do it great
buddy you live in your best life only
one moment is better than
petting doggy honestly this entire movie
is filled with honorable mentions from
how is your sex life - I just like to
watch you guys even Johnny humping
Lisa's dress they're all worthy just
free watch or watch the room and you'll
find that it's packed to the brim with
moments that only it can provide and the
number one best / worst moment from the
room is I did not hit her it's not true
it's bullshit I did not hit her I did
not oh hi mark how could it be anything
else
everybody knows oh hi mark it's been
engrained in our culture
johnny has found out that Lisa is
spreading lies that he hid her and he's
angry angry enough to kind of yell for a
water bottle then change attitude on a
dime and quarterly say hi to his friend
he did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit he did not hit her he did not
oh hi Jim this is the moment I feel like
most people point to the acting is so
absurd that the scene has become a
phenomena only Tommy Wiseau could
deliver that line in that way his style
will call it is why this movie is so
beloved the room is a one-of-a-kind film
that we both recommend you experience
both at home and at one of the
screenings - check out my review of the
disaster artist movie take a look at
last week's Orbitz report where I lay
out my thoughts on this highly
anticipated adaptation over on my
personal channel you can also see my
review of the film and if it lives up to
all the positive press it's been
receiving we want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite moment from
the room what do you want me to cover
next on the show leave us a comment and
let us know otherwise you'd find me on
social media at Facebook as I own a weed
or everywhere else as awesome Ayana or
right here in channel awesome every
Monday on Orbitz report and you can like
my Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome alter B or follow along on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future I'll
be back next week with a brand new
episode of top 5 ok wealthy bang
you